Hi, I'm a husband, I had a husband.
relations in Brazil and in this video we will
see how to add fitness to the new
versions of android to your applications and
still compatible with
previous versions of the platform where
phones that have version 2.1 2.2 other
versions
after all that is lab support is a set
of libraries that can be included in the
your application
each of these libraries supports a
android version specific group and
also gives you the possibility to use a
different group of functionalities and
you can include these libraries in the
your project in eclipse the android studio
but also in your idea it is preferred that
Are you announcing the project?
sport life is divided into five versions a
The first is to see four positive
from android 1.6 or skin takes 4
which brings features like fragments 20
where i stayed shams saw pg drug layout
for you power of those less than
slide left to right louder
which has mechanisms such as scintigraphy
improve performance your application
then we have 17 that is divided into three
different libraries that you can
use for set of
features we have up to
with the free pat he adds is
compatibility with such
expected with edson will fill action
approved
remembering that is the part of android 2.1
ap level 7 and this library is one thing
which is as follows:
so when did you add to your
Remember to check if you want to see
which was also thoughtfully added to the
eclipse
You're going to have a surprise when it comes to
combine or export only pk
Then we have a tiger once.
layout that was created specifically
you need to have a great layout in your
application is also the same thing
part of version 2.1
then we have very interesting that
is versatile media holter that can give
media support to other holter media
prove and related classes that I will
give it a google preview
cast that you could do some
applications that interact with chrome
cash for example
and last but not least
we have nine and 13 she goes
add support for fragments
applications in the applications from the
version 3.2
so you have the resources that were
presented after three points 2
was released and with tear support
version 13
Can you add it in your
application so let's learn now
how to put lake support in your project
in case I'm going to use a project that already
it's ready and eclipse
I'll make a support of this project
so we are seeing the support and the
I called the project you click with the button
right on top of the project and downstairs
a yes option is quite simple android
all selecting the titles will also
draw very easy that is the support lake
no mysteries and clicks and it will download
the library data that is
compatible with your project and then
will present a license that you have
that agreeing to such a license is the
free is open but only has to
agree to the license given to you by
of the license click accept and then
installed after that it will download the
library to add the
your project so that it can be
always use the latest version
after he has downloaded it already made the
and you can check this through
of the director where you can see
here android support aggre g 4 if you
You want three versions just in this
walk and download the version that you
interest or need and in addition to
to use eclipse together with people
you can also use the
android studio that is even easier is
only you include in addition to dependency on
the governor's script so that he can
bild puts the correct dependency on your
project
Let's have a look at each stringhi.
for each library to see 4s is in
screen where you have with a point android point
support two points support trace see
table two points 18.10 point more
Then everyone else I'm going to talk to
are based on this rule of
information and each is to put an
Specific we explained in a video
previously we have to see set efe with
part
then we will have the v7 great layout
then the media holter and finally see 13
in the case of versions 3 with 2 onwards
then the
stayed a doubt want to know more
details on the support there you can
visit the site kotaku link there that has
all explanation all tapes
in detail and if you have lost some
how to place the bracket on your
project also has a page about the
setap gives online support to help
in this process of using it and
application that is richer in
functionalities
good guys so now after seeing
this video you already know the support
from now on and can include
in your project and make use of the victims
latest android apps on your
application and still continue
supporting previous platform version
do not forget to check the documentation
official if you have any questions and
the steps indicated there in games in the
next videos